let's just make one thing clear neither
Ronaldo or Messi are the top
International goal scorers in the world
wait so why does Ronaldo's name come up
when you Google top International goal
scorer well that's because of sexism
most people including Google and the
media don't count all the female soccer
players who have way more goals if you
actually counted women and the goals
that they score for their country they
would easily be the top several places
on this list and it turns out that
Canada's Christine Sinclair would be at
the very top and yes Ronaldo would be on
the list but he would just be like kind
of in the top ten here in the United
States our national women's team has won
the FIFA World Cup four times four times
unfortunately we can't say the same
about the men's team they've never won
and they barely even make it into the
World Cup every year so yeah there's no
moral to this story I just wanted to put
some respect on these names and make
sure we we clear this up thank you